[Music]
hi my name is not Raylan I'm the owner
of Serrano creepazoid Limits during my
day I receive a wide range of phone
calls from folks about how to use
compost in their gardens and it seems in
the last few years as we've been
transitioning to irrigation systems that
conserve more water at the same time
more folks are just not getting the
results with our product that they
historically have been getting so I've
made this video as a way of trying to
explain the role between water
conservation irrigation systems compost
soil health and plant vitality the
answers for this video come from my own
experience here in my own yard
where I use a variety of irrigation
systems as well as visiting many of your
gardens and seeing how you irrigate do
you stay to the end of this video you'll
definitely have a much better
understanding of what goes on
underground how that underground is
affected by the type of irrigation you
use and ultimately the vitality of your
garden so let's get started if you think
dirt is only made up of rock and sand
and clay how wrong you are living in
that dirt are literally trillions of
organisms and it is their presence that
converts the organic matter on the
surface those leaves that bison manure
into food that feeds your plants and the
amount of life that exists underground
is orders of magnitude much more dense
that would exist above ground but
because we live above ground we give
little thought what happens below ground
so I'm gonna change your terminology
going forward dirt is what stains your
genes of plants live in soil so soil is
the dirt portion the rock the sand the
Clay's but it's also the water organic
matter in the organisms and we use that
term soil understanding this
relationship is so important that you
may want to stop this video right now
and watch one of the two videos I've
shown on the screen that's possible that
video may expire when you actually watch
this but no doubt you'll find other
videos by dr. Langham and Jeffrey Lewin
fellows they really give you a true
appreciation of how complex and how
important the organisms that live in
your soil are to the success of your
plants so let's look at an actual
cross-section of Sol
we start with dirt and on top of that
dirt is somewhere on organic matter
meaning some set of carbon-based matter
it could be from fallen leaves buffalo
manure or maybe compost we made from our
kitchen scraps into that a few seedlings
have sprouted there's a large fungal
mass associated with the roots of our
little seedling so we're going to put
those in that there are billions of
bacteria that break down the organic
matter that helps feed the soil
organisms and just for graphic purposes
we're gonna add some amoebas and
earthworms and centipedes and pull bugs
just the name of you in all these
organisms either feed from the organic
matter that's on the surface or
secondarily feed from those who bring it
into the soil and very important these
organisms just like you and I require
water to survive as well as to move
about so let's see what happens in our
simple graphic it rains and that rain
travels through the surface organic
matter into the soil below and while
this may seem very elementary when this
organic matter is wet enough a few of
our worms and pill bugs etc will move
into it consume it and then bring it
into the soil also very important
remember that soil must have moisture
for those organisms that live in the
soil who remain alive when there's a dry
area the organisms either die move away
from there if you think to an earlier
time in our lives our home irrigation
systems were pretty close to natural
rainfall looking at our graphic we can
see that while it is not truly rainfall
coming from the sky these robust
wrinkler systems were able to wet
everything and provide the moisture
content the soil organisms needed to
continue on so in the first step towards
water conservation we took the same
concept of these overhead sprinklers and
reduce them to much smaller versions of
the larger ones so if we look at our
graphic we see what happens when we
start using these sort of micro spray
systems so how does that soil change
when we go from the old standard
above-ground water everything method to
these new micro systems what we see is
that we start to get dry spots in
between the various sprinklers as these
become more pronounced the soil
organisms leave these dry areas total
population Falls and hence eventually
less nutrients are available for the
plan
while we may change our sprinkler system
all in one day the drawing of these
areas could take months maybe more if
you go through a few rainstorms we will
likely go through a honeymoon period
where the plants are thriving that was
so much less water how wonderful a new
irrigation system is that's a false
economy because eventually those dry
spots will start to form
you also notice that portions of the
surface organic matter are no longer wet
and without this moisture the very
organisms that were consuming it will
leave for wet areas their numbers will
dwindle as the amount of damn compost is
reduced the dry organic matter will no
longer support a vibrant soil it will
become hard and brittle and it makes
sense that you would think hey the
reason my yard is not doing well because
this compost is terrible let's look at a
simple chart comparing damp areas versus
dry areas so first we begin with a
natural setting or old-fashioned
thoroughly irrigated area and with
plenty of water the bacteria and fungi
flourish they're bright products open up
the soil allowing oxygen and water to
easily get to those organisms that live
in the soil and hence those produce more
nutrients for our plants and
everything's looking good now let's look
what happens when we turn off the water
the bacteria and fungi die off and soil
structure begins to collapse as it
collapses becomes more compacted oxygen
and water cannot get to the organisms
and soon anaerobic organisms colonize
the soil their byproducts don't create
plant food but instead create poisons
such as alcohols and acids which
eventually either stress or kill our
above-ground plants remember all this
takes time months or years after an
irrigation system has changed in soil
dry means dead back to our irrigation
story in an effort to save more water
we've moved from these micro spraying
systems to drip systems by now you
realize that the volume of soil that
supports a plant can be hundreds of
times larger than the above-ground plant
yet somehow we believe that a sink or a
few prepping emitters can support a
thriving soil does not make sense as we
see with these systems the dry zone is
further increased so how do these
systems get installed they don't make
sense I think it's because we view the
world through our own experiences and
when we're thirsty we can meet all our
water needs through a very small pore
called our mouth but as we know plants
do not absorb water this
they require a very large diffuse area
if you took time to watch either of
those two videos you've come to
understand it takes a lot of soil to
support a plant in an area far far
larger and what we see above-ground I
have visited struggling Gardens where
the homeowner is baffled at what is
going on that's because they have
reverted from traditional systems that
watered all the soil to maybe one or two
emitters placed at the base of a very
mature tree and as we see this cannot
possibly work continuing with our
irrigation story inline drip systems by
these few photos we can clean these wet
versus dry areas and these systems
suffer from the same problem as
conventional existence at large dry
areas here's another effect we need to
look at changing soil composition so we
may have installed an over designed drip
system that did in fact water all of our
soil but recently it seems like our
plants are really struggling as we saw
earlier it could be that there was
leftover soil moisture from the old
system that took a while to be used up
but another explanation could be that
we've worked hard to improve the organic
levels in the soil and that very action
has damaged the efficiency of this
system so let's see how that happens if
we compare clay in sandy soil they're
very different place oils tend to be
very compacted so that water is very
slow to sink in
hence water will tend to spread over a
greater area before it soaks into the
soil on the other hand sandy soils are
very porous meaning that there's a lot
of space between the particles a lot of
room for water to go in and these soils
water soaks in very quickly if you look
at a cross-section you will see two
different lighting patterns from these
two types of soil another factor is
capillary action because of the skin
effect of a water molecule in clay water
can travel sideways as well as upwards
to find gravity in very porous soils
that skin effect is greatly diminished
so water moves down so now let's look at
a drip system that was built for yard
that was all clay this year worked very
well in terms of distributing water
that's because it had capillary action
over time either organic matter is added
from falling leaves we've begun adding
compost to the surface whatever the
reason is the soil has become more
porous which is great for the organisms
that live there because now they can get
water and oxygen but unfortunately drip
systems water distribution narrows as
the soils porosity increases in
capillary
action is reduced as our soil improves
ironically we strive to see those
dreaded dry zones begin to form over
time as more organic matter into the
soil the drip system becomes less and
less capable providing the needed
moisture now we know that pure clay soil
is a little value that we must add
organic matter so keeping our soil
sterilization these systems the answer
is using only synthetic fertilizers
injected into the irrigation water any
and all organic matter must be avoided
to maximize the clay content in foster
this spreading of water so how can we
have both how can we have lush healthy
gardens as well as conserve water
hopefully by now you see that watering
the entire garden soil and that just a
base of the plant is the key to a
healthy underground soil and that
healthy soils foster healthy plants
that's something we cannot get around
the easiest and most cost effective
solution to conserving water is to mulch
over the entire surface this as much as
50% of that soil moisture can be lost to
evaporation from the Sun and the wind
this is especially true with clay soils
or that dawn capillary action will draw
moisture from deep down bring it to the
surface where it is then lost to
evaporation a layer of compost ops that
capillary draw by shading the soil from
the Sun as well as blocking the drying
effects of wind
so either mulch for three to four inches
of compost or just leave any fallen
organic matter where it fell second if
you have a drip system buried raise
those emitters up onto the surface the
reason we do this is we want our organic
matter on the surface could be wet
enough for the organisms will consume it
and integrate it into the soil if we
bury that line the compost will become
extremely dry and never get into the
soil to feed the organisms that
eventually feed the plants again
remember that all the soil needs to have
moisture putting water or there no
plants does not mean you are wasting
water shake yourself of that drinking
glass analogy if you have an inline drip
system consider adding additional lines
in my vegetable garden I initially
installed this system exactly as
detailed in the manual I've since come
back and have added twice to recommend a
number of lines with these additional
lines I also chose an emitter with a
much higher flow rate so the water would
spread rather than soak in just below
the emitter the results have been
spectacular
in my bumper crops are back another
feature I've added is a weather-based
irrigation timer now before Warren needs
to be pretty expensive in a quite
complicated to program but the water
savings can be worth the price
hey watering when it rains is the pure
waste but who remembers to run out and
turn off our irrigation system when that
happens then there the cases when
there's a heat spell and we see our
plants wilting so we do adjust the time
upwards the heats out passes but we
forget to reset our timing schedule and
as a result we over water so that
concludes a few of my thoughts about
watering and compost
I hope you've gotten a little bit better
understanding and can make more informed
decisions going forward your patience
has been most appreciated and of course
your calls are always welcome thank you
[Music]